foreign
is from Theo in France
my name is Theo I am a patreon
subscriber from France thanks to my
parents I had the chance to study in
Santa Monica California for three years
it was such an amazing experience being
with myself in a foreign country for a
while really helped me to figure out who
I am and what I want to do with my life
sadly my dad passed away a few months
after I came back home it's been four
years already and I feel like it
happened yesterday I haven't accepted
completely that he's gone I have a lot
of regrets about being away for such a
long time and not spend this time with
him there are so many things that I wish
I had said to him do you have any advice
on how to move on with my life how can I
let go of these regrets
I think Theo's touching on something
that most of us deal with at some point
my mother died it was the whole start of
this minimalist thing I was with Ryan
when my mother died and I was 28 at the
time and I was actually in the car with
Ryan when I got the phone I was flying
down to Florida he was I was literally
on Terminal Drive in Dayton Ohio when I
got this phone call and I think some of
the greatest regrets in my life at one
point were not spending more time or
hear all the things I should have done
or could have done I wish I would have
done that's where Theo is right now and
it's really hard to move on if you
haven't let go of that I um recently
started reading a book by B.J Miller and
shoshana buyer a beginner's guide to the
end
and in there they interview a palliative
care physician named
um Dr Ira bilock and he talks about the
four things
that
he encourages people to say with some to
someone when that person is dying or
even if they have died say it to that
person and these four things really
helped me out the first thing was please
forgive me
for my indiscretions you know for the
things for the ways that I've wronged
you intentionally unintentionally please
forgive me
second thing is I forgive you
and how powerful is that right that's
part of the Letting Go please forgive me
I forgive you
the next thing was thank you just simply
thank you thank you for being you for
being in my life for being this
expression of love and joy
for this period of time that we've had
together
and the fourth the fourth thing is I
love you
and expressing those things has helped
me Let Go not just of my mother and her
previous form but let go of the clinging
uh to I wish I would have done things
differently if I just would have done X
Y and Z then things would have been
perfect or better or whatever right the
fifth thing he talked about that he's
learned after dealing with a lot of
dying people is he said I've even dealt
with 60 70 year old men and the one
thing they can't get over is their
father never said I'm proud of you
um and holding on to that I wish my
father would have just said I'm proud of
you so if you're a father or mother or
caregiver listening to this
maybe telling your son or daughter right
now that hey I'm proud of you the way it
doesn't haunt them the uh the rest of
their lives Zach what do you have to say
about this question from Theo
great stuff
um yeah that's the Hope on a prayer that
you just outlined in those four steps I
am sorry please forgive me uh thank you
I love you you know and those those four
steps of this ancient Hawaiian prayer
have been used for Millennia to resolve
Wars and to resolve Conflict at the you
know kind of superstructure of as well
as in relationship and within the
individual and I think it's down at that
individual level that the prayer becomes
most powerful when was last time you
said I am sorry to yourself to your soul
for having put so many other things in
front of yourself
you were so I have so disregarded my own
sacred Soul the infinite Within Me by
building a whole metric of success or a
metric of value in myself and putting
everything else before my own soul
my own connection to that soul and so
that whole upon a prayer is so powerful
to begin it yourself and then
I think you get to tell your loved one
who's dying a more clean version of that
because ultimately most the crap that
we're gonna ask for forgiveness or
forgive is actually within ourselves and
not our relationship to that person
we've we've projected so much on that
relationship of our internal Journey
that we are refusing to understand as
our own and so in these relationships of
family family is such a challenging
landscape emotionally right we all have
challenges of communication and how do
you stay for decades with this group of
people that are your family when you're
on extraordinarily different Pathways so
what does that look like in all this
and so forgiving yourself beginning in
that I am sorry I free I forgive you
thank you and I love you to self and
just stay in the joy that comes out of
that for a minute and then take it to
your loved one and say wow I just
experienced this inside myself I have
freedom within myself right now and I
want to I want you to feel my freedom
when I say please forgive me or I
forgive you I want you to feel my
freedom in my exchange of that and when
I say thank you and I love you I want
you to feel the sincerity the vibration
because I did the work inside first
and so death can be one of these things
where we are thrust into these deep
Communications
but if we don't begin itself we maybe
miss this this little opportunity that
we have to clear the Slate internally
and then move into this exchange of what
being witness to somebody who's just on
that Veil and Crossing back and forth
across the veil what a powerful moment
to say I remember everything I know I'm
sorry forgive me I forgive you but know
as you go into the infinite that I am
here and I love you and I love myself
and I am free and the vibration that's
set up across the quantum space at that
point you know resolves any need for the
Psychotherapy and all the hundreds of
hours on the couch because it's a true
letting go it's the the true dumping of
that water crystal you were asking about
earlier and so that whole point of
prayer is super powerful in there
but in regards to his question of you
know I don't feel like I can let go of
my father
there's a a deep misperception that we
are actually separate from father you
know yeah and so this is where the
clinging can become its own Problem by
clinging to the memory of your father
you're not allowing your father to
express itself within you you have
father within you you have mother when
you may not have even known your father
in this lifetime and father is within
you there's a whole line of patriarchy
in your past there's a whole line of
matriarchy in your past and it is
expressing itself and now that we know
about genetics it's so literal it's so
literal what we have here in our bodies
is a incredible Data Bank of the memory
of everything and genetics is is
constantly updated in itself to
experience the now and put it into the
genetic record and so it's a beautiful
Journey as a biologic being of
remembrance at that at the atomic level
really down within you and so your
father is within you and by letting go
of the construct of the memory and
letting it be the real reality let go of
remembering and become it become your
father become that energetic you know
translation of your father within you
and you're going to meet your father in
a whole new way because it's going to
start acting through you it's not going
to be a memory of the past it's going to
be an active present moment experience
of father and that's that's going to
really be an incredible way to honor
your father and to experience the father
within you
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free